indignation film auteur avec son roman
bonheur d'occasion
l'écrivaine gabrielle roy a été la
première canadienne à remporter en 1947
le prix femina cette pionnière qui a
quitté son manitoba natale pour d'autres
horizons inspire l'écrivaine québécoise
dominique fortier pour moi gabrielle roy
c'est vraiment un exemple de femme libre
c'est quelqu'un qui ose et se choisira
une époque où c'était vraiment pas
facile de faire ça pour une femme
quitter son milieu quitté sa mère un
moment où sa mère avait vraiment besoin
d'elle mais un partez pour un voyage
qu'il avait planifié depuis longtemps
pièce avait que 600 n'allait pas ce
moment-là partirai jamais gabrielle roy
est l'une des quatre femmes à être
désignée comme personnage historique par
le gouvernement du québec s'ajoute à la
liste
judith jasmin journaliste pour radio
canada dès 1947 où elle deviendra la
première femme québécoise à faire des
reportages à l'étranger justesse mais
pour moi c'est un grand modèle gelé
connu à mon adolescence alors que je
rêvais de devenir journaliste quand je
la voyais depuis new york je me disais
comment est ce possible de rêver de se
retrouver à new york ouvrir les grands
événements sa qualité de lang son ton
solennel elle incarnait formes
classiques du journalisme dans les
années 60 c'était inspirant robertine
barry premières femmes à vivre du métier
de journaliste au québec et laure conan
la toute première femme francophone
avoir fait carrière en littérature au
canada sont aussi honoré en cette
journée internationale des droits des
femmes terre aviez de la malbaie
l'orkhon puis dans charlevoix
les gens parlaient beaucoup d'elle a
montré du doigt c'était une originale
une avant-gardiste déjà au dix neuvième
siècle c'est une femme qui voulait pas
avoir une vie de femme rangée est ce que
voulait se consacrer aux mots à la
littérature
gabrielle roy judith jasmin robertine
barry et laure conan ont marqué notre
histoire
il y a aussi le devoir de mémoire je
pense que je m'en rends compte encore
plus depuis la naissance de ma fille
aujourd'hui on marche dans leurs traces
importantes issues de ces femmes qui ont
fait les premiers pas c'est comme les
premiers pas sur la lune c'est dans un
autre monde
de votre mère dans ce que vous êtes ici
louis philippe ouimet radio-canada moria